le texte de mise en accusation rédigé
par les élus démocrates pour tenté de
destituer donald trump est déjà prêt ils
devraient être envoyées cette semaine au
sénat après le vote de la chambre des
représentants le but écarter
définitivement donald trump du pouvoir
il peut seulement accorder son propre
pardon pour des délits fédéraux ne peut
pas si innocente et pour des délits
détail c'est pourquoi il est mis en
examen dans l'état de new york
c'est l'une des motivations que les gens
ont pour préconiser un impeachment et
bien j'aime le 25e amendement parce que
ça nous débarrasse de lui il n'est plus
en fonction
mais il ya un fort soutien au congrès
pour mettre en accusation le président
une seconde fois le texte reproche à
l'actuel président des états unis
d'avoir mis en danger la sécurité du
pays lors de l'assaut du capitole le 6
janvier dernier une procédure de
destitution qui vise aussi à juger
donald trump
même après la fin de son mandat dans le
but qu'ils ne puissent plus être
candidat à une élection présidentielle
une manoeuvre qui a donc lieu quelques
jours avant la cérémonie d'investiture
de joe biden qui serait selon certains
documents du fbi avait menacé par de
nombreuses manifestations dans le pays
une situation qui n'inquiète par le
président ait eu
je n'ai pas peur de prêter serment en
plein air et je me fais briefé je pense
qu'il est essentiel de veiller très
sérieusement à ce que les personnes qui
se sont livrées à l'insurrection et qui
ont menacé la vie de personnes qui ont
souillé la propriété publique qui ont
causé de grands dégâts soient tenus pour
responsables et l'inquiétude gagne du
terrain aussi dans le camp du président
républicain
hier le ministre par intérim de la
sécurité intérieure à a présenté sa
démission
une cérémonie d'investiture qui devrait
donc se dérouler dans un contexte
particulièrement tendu
le pentagone a autorisé le déploiement
de quinze mille soldats de la garde
nationale à washington donald trump a
déjà confirmé son absence lors de la
cérémonie d'investiture une bonne chose
a estimé joe biden